sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana luno if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
highway fan show as always that is
powered by icon plus capital and it is
sponsored by blockfi so today i am in
miami i'm very excited we're here for
the bitcoin conference and i thought i
would get in some interviews from some
very high profile people in the space so
joining me today is a man that i don't
think needs much introduction but it is
bitcoiner robert breedlove
i'm honored that i fit your category of
high-profile people i think so
oh it's my absolute pleasure and you're
obviously the host of the what is money
show
yes um we've been doing it for almost a
year and a half now and it's been quite
successful so i'm very very humbled by
it and consider myself very grateful and
lucky to be able to do what i love every
day i totally agree with you i totally
understand that um but i'm curious about
your background before bitcoin i know
that you're a hedge fund guy
so talk to me about your background
yeah so i have a master's degree in
accounting and finance so straight out
of school i was actually in public
accounting for a number of years uh
basically focusing on tax strategy for
high net worth people and investment
partnerships
and businesses
so i kind of saw the belly of the beast
so to speak in terms of how people
navigate
tax law and exploit loopholes and
preserve capital and all of that
um
but quickly discovered that was not the
business for me
it's funny now that i speak out against
statism and taxation but i actually have
a master's degree in taxation which is a
little bit weird
i then got into
basically the entrepreneurial path i was
a cfo for a number of tech companies
uh early in mid-stage
and then
basically fell into the bitcoin rabbit
hole late 16 early 17 and that's when i
got into the hedge fund business so i
originally started a multi-strategy
crypto asset fund so we're trading in
and out of a lot of positions a lot of
coins
and then over time as i was writing my
monthly investor updates and just trying
to get my head around bitcoin i kept
falling more and more into the bitcoin
rabbit hole so
becoming much more focused on bitcoin at
the exclusion of everything else
um
finally in 2020 my
i guess a lot of people had realizations
that year my realization was
that i was spending all my blood sweat
and tears
in this hedge fund business trying to
outperform bitcoin which is the best
performing asset in human history
uh when i could just pivot to like
basically an accumulation position like
i did with my personal wealth
and then free up all my time
so that's basically what i did and then
i had this idea
inspired by a lot of things but um
partly by jordan peterson you know he
has a successful podcast
he talks about this technological
revolution that we're in with youtube
and podcasting that effectively the cost
of bandwidth has gone to zero so we can
talk about anything and distribute it to
the world at almost zero cost
so i thought um
i would kind of zig while everyone else
is zagging a lot of people if you go on
youtube or podcast there's a lot of just
surface level discussion occurring i
thought i would
uh capitalize on the low cost of
bandwidth and just do deep dives on
whatever topics i wanted to
and the main question i think in the
bitcoin rabbit hole is what is money
right like if you you need to answer
that question for yourself
not that it has one final answer but
it's got a lot
to understand the implications of
bitcoin itself
and uh serendipitously at that time i
was going to start the show
mr sailor dm'd me
said he had just bought a lot of bitcoin
and he appreciated my work so i invited
him on to be my first guest
and the sailor series
is now 17 episodes long
and that's been a big success so that
really launched the show
and um
yeah i spend all my time reading writing
and talking to the smartest people in
the world about big ideas so very happy
about that yeah i really enjoyed the um
the sailor podcast um i watched pretty
much all of those those series but
you're always asking people what is
money and i think michael sailor has
this really um technical approach with
it almost quite like a physicist almost
um but you're quite philosophical when
you speak about bitcoin
would you regard yourself as a
philosophical person and what sort of
philosophy do you live by and how has
that philosophy impacted your life
yeah i've naturally always been
predisposed to deeper conversations
never been much for small talk i'm also
i can be an overthinker too like before
when i was younger before i got into
yoga actually yoga and meditation really
helped me figure out how to not be an
overthinker how to balance that out
i just
found myself
intellectualizing about things all the
time thinking about things all the time
but i never considered myself to be a
philosopher per se but i guess
the nature of philosophy is
first of all it means love of wisdom
right philia sophia
but it really has to do with inquiring
into the fundamental nature of things so
if you've ever hung out with like a two
or three year old kid and they're just
asking why this why that why this why
that that's literally the child trying
to establish their philosophical anchor
points to the world so they know how to
move through the world
and i guess i just never stopped asking
why about things
um
and
i i don't know i don't know how to turn
it off or whatever and now
i'm fine with philosopher as a label
people have given me that the only thing
i don't like is when they say
self-proclaimed philosopher because i
think that's a bit
a bit trite for somebody to do that and
i don't
label myself as such
i do label myself however as a freedom
maximalist i think that just captures
my deepest beliefs um
for myself and what i want to give
others as well i think there's a weird
thing about freedom and that when we
maximize it not only do we maximize our
satisfaction in life but we also create
more wealth and more satisfaction of
human wants
on a global scale
so
we know that sort of in america we have
this western civilization
tradition
but in recent years you know
specifically with the introduction of
central banking and fiat over the past
century we've started to regress against
that
and i think bitcoin is just um
the purest form we've ever had of of a
an implementation of the principles of
western civilization like it is life
liberty and property
incarnate in many ways so
um i'm just
so
happy that bitcoin exists right now
given how crazy the world is going
and i'm just thrilled to be a part of
this
mission to educate but but i don't want
to say like it's not me educating people
i actually consider what i do learning
out loud like i'm just i'm learning i'm
talking to people i want to talk to
about topics i want to talk about
that i find interesting that advance my
knowledge and then i get to share that
dialogue with the world and people
engage with that you know they can sense
when you're
i guess surfing the edge of your own
understanding
and hopefully exchanging ideas with
people that
produce insights that you could not do
broadcasting from a podium if that makes
sense
yeah i mean these podcast situations you
can get into so much more detail
um you know you talk about what is money
so with all those conversations that
you've had
in your opinion what is money is it a
store of value
is it um is it a means of transacting
or is it a transfer of energy like
sailor says
you would think for a guy that runs a
show called the what is money show i'd
have some canned response for this when
i go on other shows but i actually have
a document with over 50 answers to that
question and i've been actually writing
on my sub stack i've been publishing
uh basically a series of answers to that
question like money is this money is
that money is this i never know which
one to pick when someone asks me but
today
the one that comes to mind first is that
money is quite simply
a title to human time
so
we many of us probably own stocks or
have owned stocks at some point
all that represents is an ownership
claim
on the capital of that company
ultimately like if you go all the way to
the bottom of the stock certificate
and i think you can
view money in a similar way in that
instead of being a title to a specific
company's capital
it's a title to the global capital stock
right money can be used to acquire
anything the marketplace can bear this
is any product
any good service knowledge whatever it
may be
and all of those things are themselves
products of human time there's nothing
that doesn't take human time to produce
right like even people want to talk
about land or even land takes hands to
sale takes takes time to sell
so
in that sense
money is really the most important form
of property
humans have
and
the more we economize our efforts so the
deeper
we subdivide labor this is called like
the economic division of labor basically
the more intensity of exchange we have
and the longer more roundabout our
production processes are
the more capital we can produce per unit
of human time
so money ends up just being a claim on
that that uh economic surplus we create
through cooperation
and it's frankly just the most important
tool humans can wield
so that's that's a temporal aspect on
money like as you mentioned sailor has
this whole energy aspect on money which
is also equally fascinating and
complementary in a lot of ways
and um
yeah that's just one example of i never
thought of money that way before talking
to sailor and there's other like i
talked to
um
oh his name escapes me at the moment
he's basically uh
he's
an evolutionary biologist and he
described money as liquid fitness right
like in a darwinian sense so there's all
these unique answers that have come out
of these conversations that just keep
enriching my viewpoint and giving me new
answers to write about on what is money
and you said that right now you're
particularly happy that bitcoin exists
and you said that bitcoin really
encompasses what western society is
supposed to be freedom liberty and all
of that so
i'd like to get into that
why particularly right now are you happy
that bitcoin exists what is the problem
for you right now that bitcoin is
solving well the problem in the world is
excessive overgrowth of the state or
government um
you know when you get into the
libertarian rabbit hole you come to see
government as the only business let's
say non-criminal business
that does
that derives its revenue from
involuntary exchange
every other business it's voluntary
right you go to buy the car you're
negotiating a price
you reach a point and you execute the
transaction or you don't
buyer and seller always have a say so in
every trade and every business in the
world
that's not the case with government
we've been stuck in this
it's almost like a technological problem
i think pre-bitcoin that we've been
stuck with a situation of
how do we
preserve the integrity of the
relationship between people and their
stuff owners and assets
that relationship itself by the way is
property right
how do we preserve that relationship
in a way so we have to outsource the
physical security right someone has to
you have a deed to your house so if
someone comes in and sleeps on your
couch you can call you know
the cops or whatever security force to
remove that person
how do we preserve that relationship
between people and their stuff in a way
that the security provider that's
securing that relationship
does not use their security measures
to abuse that relationship
and so that's what the state is like
we've outsourced all of our physical
security to one monopoly on violence
effectively
and then we just trust them to charge us
the right price we don't negotiate it's
almost unnegotiable yes for most people
99.99 of people
there is a certain echelon of if you're
you know a billionaire or you're a
multinational conglomerate you can
actually negotiate with nation states
because you've developed so much
negotiating leverage but for the vast
vast majority of people it's just not
the case
so
and when you have that it's almost a
contradiction in terms in a way
because you basically have the state
saying
hey
pay me to preserve this relationship
between you and your stuff whatever
amount i tell you
or i'll take your stuff
so that's been like our our best
solution to the problem of property up
until this point and that is by the way
the exclusive purpose of government we
get into these weird like we think
governments are supposed to do these
other things that
uh you know preserve the greater good or
um whatever but that's all nebulous and
doesn't make a lot of sense like the
fundamental economic
purpose of government is property
so we've had this weird thing where
we've always needed the monopoly on
violence to honor the property rights
well along comes bitcoin i guess before
that
where we are today
it's like that uh institution that
monopoly on violence is now preying on
the property rights of people heavily
um
and
this is important to know too fiat
currency inflation when they're printing
money
we could think about that one order deep
and we think that's a good thing but
what's actually happening is just a
transfer of wealth from
the people that can't print money to the
people that can print money that's
that's all it does
printing money doesn't add any new
productive factors to the economy so
it's purely a mechanism for wealth to
transfer or so differently property
violation
fiat currency inflation is a violation
of property rights so what are we doing
in the post-covered world
we're rampantly violating when i say we
the state is rampantly violating the
property rights of citizens worldwide
every central bank worldwide is printing
money
to save the economy to help people out
and people believe it because they don't
understand money
so
bitcoin is important because finally
citizens have an option
to preserve their wealth in a medium or
form of property that lives independent
of the monopoly on violence you just
basically the miners are providing the
security in the case of bitcoin
um at a fair price right they can't
coerce you to use bitcoin they can't
uh
all of the transaction fees are done in
a free market manner there's not there's
not a course of element within bitcoin
so that gives
citizens that may be
being preyed upon or oppressed by the
state in terms of having their property
violated an alternative an opt-out
and so just by giving people that option
to exit i think in the long run it
actually forces government to behave
more honestly to actually treat people
like customers
rather than subjects
and so
that's what i'm trying to educate people
about like
property is the sole purpose of
government property is also the basis of
civilization
like ayn rand said if you can't if a man
cannot control the fruit of his own
labor there he has no other rights all
human rights
everything that we think is good civil
liberties all these things it's built on
property
and so finally we have a property that's
independent of the state cannot be
inflated cannot be manipulated can it be
corrupted
and that simple opt-out option
forces governments to deal with this
more honestly so but we live in a
society whereby this is a very
libertarian mindset and it's one that i
share
and the idea that we should have a small
government if one if any at all um is a
very
niche
idea particularly in 2022
um so if that if property is just the
sole purpose
how did we get to a point where the
government really is in every aspect of
our lives even to the point where
we will protect you take this medicine
because we know that this is better for
you how did we get to a point where the
government is in every aspect of our
lives central banking and fiat currency
right a government
effectively by having a central bank
implemented inside of a country
the government effectively has
a mechanism of unlimited revenue and you
could also say a mechanism of limited
liability so they a government can go
and spend and borrow as much as it likes
misallocate as much capital as it wants
run huge deficits losses right and
an economic deficit or loss that means
you're not you're spending resources
that are not satisfying humans
you're wasting resources that's what it
means
but when a government can just print new
money to pay for this paper over this
bad decision making this capital
misallocation
and then externalize the cost of all
that money printing onto the productive
society
they're just confiscating wealth from
productive people
that are running profitable businesses
creating
valuable goods and services in the world
and then channeling it into the
government misallocation of capital
so it's
a business that can never lose right
it's heads i win tells you lose from the
state's perspective
they can make bad decisions screw it all
up oh well just print more money i'll
confiscate wealth from everyone that was
successful in the marketplace
and then reallocate capital further so
fiat currency has led to the overgrowth
of the state it's led to an overemphasis
i argue on politics
people have such
a deep connection to their personal
political identity and their collective
political identity they really think
that's the most important thing in the
world right are you liberal are you
conservative are you ready i think these
days i find that very important know
what somebody is just in case i think
it's all
premised on the viability of property
because in this hypothetical world where
you can't hurt me and you can't steal my
stuff this would be this just a
hypothetical world that's not even
possible it's an ideal
but in a world where you can't hurt me
you can't steal my stuff why would we
ever argue about political opinions why
would we ever try to put ourselves under
one roof if we don't get along we don't
see eye to eye about whatever issue it
is whatever social issue it is we would
just go our separate ways
so just so i can understand you're
essentially saying because you we have a
central banking system
those at the top can print more money
which ultimately gives them more power
which introduces that monopoly on
property rights and by and being able to
have that authority to confiscate and to
threaten with violence you know if you
don't do as i say
am i am i understanding or am i missing
it somewhat like that so again if we're
looking at money as title to human time
we could also
label the central bank as an institution
of systemized time theft so they're
printing money right doling it out
arbitrarily to a
politically advantaged or connected few
at the expense of everyone else
so at the heart of the quote unquote
free market
capitalist economy that we say we have
in the united states we have an
anti-capitalist organization
that steals from everyone that's
productive and successful and allocates
the stolen proceeds to those who are
unsuccessful
and we end up with things like zombie
companies
we end up with just all the political
nonsense we see today like these people
have just lost their mind you see it in
their character you see it in their
their duplicity right they're saying one
thing doing another
so
although money is like purely a
technological it's a kind of a social
technology
i think the implications of corrupting
money actually have like they create a
spiritual pathology on the world
that we we end up in this world where we
think we need to impose our opinions on
other people
which is
anti-libertarian anti-freedom
wealth destructive right so all this is
anti-economic everything that we've
figured out to construct western
civilization the concept of fiat
meaning
do this because i said so or i will hurt
you that's what fiat means
same thing you use with your kids right
clean up your room or you're going to
get a spanking
that's fiat
that does not work in the sphere of
adult relations in my opinion i think
it's net value destructive net capital
destructive i think it's corrosive to
our character and our behavior and i
think that is
where we're at today we're sick
we're very sick
and without something like bitcoin i
would be very
pessimistic about the world
i felt that pessimism but also that
optimism during 2021 with the lockdowns
and i felt you know at least
just on a surface level i sort of
thought well you know they can take away
your job they can take away um your
rights to your body they can take away
your right of your freedom of movement
but they can't confiscate your money
um but you tweeted something which i
thought was really um entertaining and i
actually thought it was a joke when you
first tweeted it um it was somebody
talking about their pronouns um and
trying to tell their child that it's
it's it's he him not she her
and i think i believe this was a
biological woman um and you said that
this is fiat induced psychosis now a lot
of people refer to things
like let's just say like a blue tick on
twitter as oh that's fiat i don't want
that so that's sort of what i thought
you were saying but you actually mean it
this woke culture this new wave of um
so-called progressive liberalism is fiat
induced so can you go into more detail
on how
can you go into more detail on how this
wave of work culture is fiat induced
yeah this is uh
admittedly i'm kind of like at the edge
of my own understanding about a lot of
this but uh
you know one of the things peterson
highlighted years ago was he was not
going to give in to compelled speech
there were laws being passed in canada
that said
you must call this person whatever
gender they select for themselves
and through his studies of history he
knew once you started to violate the
freedom of speech
you would now be on a slippery slope
toward totalitarianism
and so
i think there's something about
again fiat existing in the world and
it's not just currency people always
especially in bitcoin think it's just
the money but legislation by fiat right
um would you mean legislation by fiat
the english common law tradition
was originally
there we would observe how people
behaved over many long periods of time
how things had been resolved
traditionally and that discovery process
would be implemented as law
it wouldn't be one guy sitting down
writing a law saying this is law it was
an observational discovery process
rather than a process of dictate which
is legislation by fiat do again do this
or i'll hurt you
so and the you know like ancient romans
didn't even have a concept of that they
actually thought all law was basically
natural law and the job of the rulers
was to discover this and and codify it
not to sit there and write laws and tell
people what to do so again we're sick
like we think this is how we have to do
things we need to coerce people into
good behavior
and when you have that
perspective in mind it you end up
creating this
fight where everyone wants to get
on the side of the coercive apparatus
to try and tell other people what to do
according to their worldview so
everyone's trying to impose their
opinions on others and i think that
whole this whole idea of
pronouns right
i'm a flag i'm a chair like it gets
absolutely crazy and then if you don't
remember my pronoun and use my pronoun
then i'm gonna coerce you i'm gonna
shame you i'm gonna cancel you like this
is asinine that's all anti-free speech
right if you ask me to call you the
pronoun and you're my friend and you're
nice about it maybe we can mutually
agree and i'll agree to do that sure
but to try and codify this
like actually bringing to bear
legal compulsion on people that do not
speak the pronoun that you wish
to be called i mean this is like
an adult playing imaginary effectively
like i want to be
whatever pronoun i've selected and if
you don't call me that thing i'm going
to hurt you so they're like trying to
impose opinion or impose imaginary play
in the adult world so i think this is
all
contributing to that psychotic behavior
um
and it sort of feeds back onto itself
too where it's like if you do give in to
that coercion then all of a sudden like
you know you've been taken advantage of
in a certain way so you feel like you
have to play that game
um
and it's just very psychologically
spiritually cancerous in my opinion and
i think we need to be rid of all of it
we just need freedom like mutual
consensual exchange across the board we
need to
absolutely put that at the highest
echelon of our value hierarchy and just
like respect and acknowledge that even
in a purely economic sense that's the
only way you create value
like a mutual this is called the
inequality of exchange in economics
two people only trade when you and i
would only execute a trade if you think
what i have is more valuable to you and
i think the same thing in reverse i
think whatever you have is more valuable
to me than what i'm giving up that's the
only time we trade
so when we both leave that trade we've
both produced a psychological profit
we're both better off i got more value
than i gave up you got more value than
you gave up we we increase the aggregate
value or at least the perception of
value in the world
only if it's mutual on both sides
if it's not mutual then it's destructive
right someone's leaving that exchange
hurt basically
and so this idea of compulsion coercion
imposition i think it just needs to be
wiped
from human affairs completely
the thing the thing with that is that it
becomes inherently political because
where there's people there's politics
right and the i think freedom is just a
political standpoint
if you if you you know take the
four-point spectrum whether it's um you
know authoritarianism liberalism whether
it's left right you know whatever it is
so a lot of people say that bitcoin
isn't political um and i understand that
you know the technology isn't political
but what you're saying to me and i
entirely agree
is inherently political it's a
libertarianism what's your definition of
politics
my definition of politics would be
i mean well
it's a hard question um i think where
there's people where there's people that
are obsessed with it they can't define
it that's a good one
where there's people there's politics
right
i again it depends on the definition
here's two definitions
that i've heard that i think makes sense
one is
something like the marketplace
is the sphere of distributed cognition
so this is where people are trading with
one another we can all all the
information basically in the marketplace
is contained in the price
so we're engaging like our individual
cognitive computational system is
plugged into the market which is like
the minds of everyone else so it's a
distributed computing system
i've heard politics defined as the
ethics of that system right so there's a
cognitive element which is the
distributed cognition of the market well
we also need distributed ethics put
right on top of that that definition of
politics i can work with right sure we
need some ethical considerations we need
to hash that out we need to talk about
it
the other definition of politics which i
think is much more
apt to modern reality
is this idea of imposing your opinion
yes right we vote world or nationwide
51 of the people decide they want this
thing then the law is written by fiat
and imposed on the other 49 percent
basically that's coercion
that i think is nonsense it's like just
just give people the ability to opt out
exit say no
then you are honoring their sovereignty
you're honoring individual decision
making
and that leads to
human flourishing in my opinion value
creation capital accumulation
satisfaction of human wants
so
depending on how we define a
politics uh i would agree with you
wherever there are people there are
politics in the sense there are ethics
to this system of distributed cognition
we have to engage in to be smart
successful creating wealth
uh advancing civilization frankly but
this other idea of politics where
i need to shove my opinion down other
people's throat because of
i don't know where people get it
honestly i can't even
i've never wanted in my life
ever to like impose my opinion or
control someone like that i just don't
i don't know where that comes from
your biggest problem then as a freedom
maximalist and i feel your maximalist
kind of says it all really is doesn't it
is is the imposing right so sort of
mandating something no coercion no
compulsion no violence
okay
so this is interesting el salvador makes
bitcoin legal tender
um and that's all very exciting um but
some issues that i've heard people have
and this is something which is hushed
away and we're sort of not allowed to
talk about is the fact that
yeah so you so you have to use it well
you could use dollars as well or not you
can use dollars as well i don't know
okay but it has to be accepted because
it's legal tender so if you go to
mcdonald's and you want to buy happy
meal whatever it is
you have to accept it a private business
has to accept it i disagree with that
you don't you disagree with i disagree
with legal tender law
completely because it is coercion it is
compulsion even though it serves the
adoption of bitcoin i still don't agree
with it
why don't you think people talk about
that
i don't know i didn't know people don't
talk about that i'll talk about it i
don't support it
that's interesting um you have this
mindset as well that bitcoin fixes this
and i really want to get into that more
um because it's sort of a cliche that we
hear online quite a lot um particularly
about war you have this theory about war
um and
what is your theory about war how does
bitcoin prevent war
yeah let me answer i would like to
define freedom maximalism actually um
and then i'll answer that question so
typically maximalism means
you're going to
maximize a metric at all other costs
right so if you were a
what's that dangerous they always talk
about the
hypothetical dangerous artificial
intelligence if it was a staple maker or
maybe it's a paper clip maker right that
it would just maximize paper clip
production at the cost of everything
else in the world before you know it
would all be drowning in paper clips
right so maximalism's typically used as
a derogatory term and
i believe bitcoin maximalism was
originally a derogatory term from
vitalik
but i want to speak i think freedom is
specifically unique
um and i've had it out with actually
bellagi on my show about this he's like
you can't beat maximalism you want to
talk about more optimalism so you want
to maximize a certain metric within some
limiting principle right so you're not
drowning in paper clips so to speak
freedom maximalism in my view though is
i want everyone to maximize their
freedom in terms of
freedom from coercion
freedom to do things so this would be
actually as we accumulate more capital
we're basically giving ourselves more
options right we can do things that we
couldn't do without that capital
um you said you flew here from dubai
right that was not an option 200 300
years ago right just didn't exist
because we didn't innovate that
so
i think freedom maximism
is maximize freedom
within the limiting principle
of the private property of others yeah
so it is self-optimizing because
property itself is an expression of
freedom it's the fruit of your past
freedom
so i think the ideal world is everyone
maximizing their own freedom
within the limiting principle or within
the boundaries of the private property
which is the freedom of others
so i think it's a
self-optimalizing to use the bellagi
term
ideal so when i say freedom maximalism
that's what i mean like
just on that point then why would you
why'd you regard yourself as a freedom
maximalist rather than a bitcoin
maximalist
because
i think bitcoin mac i clearly support
bitcoin heavily but this idea i see it
in the bitcoin community that they
become toxic they want to attack people
for their portfolio construction they
want to moralize people for their
anything communications assets they hold
i just don't believe in that
i don't want to be a part of that
culture i'm not going to go shame people
for what they buy buy whatever you want
i'll see you in the marketplace my money
will out compete yours or so i believe
maybe you're right maybe you'll out
compete me i have no idea
and to try and attack people it just
feels very high school um and i think
it's also
decremental to experimentation like let
people experiment all these [ __ ] coins
like i consider them to be mostly test
net for bitcoin but that doesn't mean
i'm gonna like dogmatically attack
people and write these long treatises
about why ethereum sucks and like more
power to you if you want to do that
that's fine but i personally
want to identify with the deeper
principle you know bitcoin's the
greatest implementation i think we've
ever had of life liberty property which
is freedom
but i don't want to dogmatically
associate myself with a culture that i
just don't identify with so in terms of
bitcoin fixing it then
talk to me about war how does bitcoin
essentially prevent war because i
believe that that's what you say right
yeah and i want to be clear about this
oftentimes when you talk about these big
topics people just
think in binaries it's like there's
either war or there's no war right it's
like not necessarily in my opinion
everything in reality exists on a
continuum
so
and the
the premise behind this thinking is you
know this is the old charlie munger
quote show me the incentive i'll show
you the outcome
so we have these institutions
called states
they're monopolist on violence they're
charged with preserving the property
rights of their citizens right keeping
the peace so people can trade and
increase wealth
but
they tend to bump up against other
states all right and
people being the territorial species
that we are
and
the state being a business i think this
is very important to you that
all human organizations are businesses
so they're all growth oriented they're
all trying to grow all trying to expand
revenue trying to become more profitable
this includes government this includes
your church this includes every
organization or club you've ever been a
part of like it has to have more
economic inflows and outflows otherwise
it doesn't exist right this is darwinian
in a way
so
throughout history
you know we had the issue where we
needed to and
i'm just going to say we needed to i'm
not 100 sure we needed the state so much
as it's been imposed upon us but we'll
just say we needed this
security outfit to preserve property to
have trade basically to have economies
well when those economic enclaves bump
into each other and they're they're both
trying to grow right they're both trying
to expand their territorial footprint
what happens
conflict develops typically over
resources also over land
it gets painted over with a lot of moral
[ __ ] like oh we're capitalists and
you're communists and we need to bang
our belief systems together
uh this is a point i deeply disagree
with peterson on he thinks it's not
economic he thinks we go to war over our
belief systems on principle completely
disagree with that
because
war is the most anti-economic thing you
can do
if you can't pay for it then you can't
do it then you're going to lose
basically
so
that's been the norm of human history
um but when you get into a world again
where you have this in this property
right independent of the state
bitcoin being secured by the mining
network
you can no longer fund warfare through
inflation
this is really important because the
atrocities in world war 1 and world war
ii of the 20th century
the scale and scope and severity of war
was unlike anything we had ever seen
because of the central bank
historically governments or these states
would bump into each other they go to
war war is the most expensive thing you
can do
they could only fund that warfare from
their own balance sheet from their own
war chest so typically two states go to
war
someone gets in financial straits they
cut a deal they sign a treaty there's an
armistice whatever
well when you install a central bank all
of a sudden
that balance sheet or war chest that
they were confined to their own
monetary reserve is now expanded to the
entire savings of civilization because
they can print money to keep paying for
for the war effort until they
hyperinflate the currency and collapse
they confiscate all the wealth from the
entire country versus just the state
so again this led to the overgrowth of
the state and therefore the overgrowth
of warfare basically
so
by virtue of bitcoin existing as an
option
to opt out of that inflationary
environment that inflationary means of
funding large-scale warfare
states now have to go back to the
original means of funding war which is
explicit taxes like i'm sending you a
bill
or borrowing
this is much more visible and visceral
for people i think the numbers
the u.s war on terror was something like
80 000 for us household wow right
but it was all printed
so if you showed up at someone's
household with a bill for 80 000 like
hey we're blowing up some people on the
other side of the world to preserve some
oil interest for me and my buddies i
need you to pay this bill
that's why people are going to put up a
lot more resistance right when they're
when it's you can see it
versus just printing money and no one
understands it and everyone just feels
the pain and then when prices increase
right the actual tax is being inflicted
what do government bureaucrats say oh
it's the greedy capitalist it's the
greedy gas stations why gas prices are
up it's the greedy food manufacturers
why why the cost of food is increasing
they'll say anything but debasing the
currency so they can obfuscate this
behind people's ignorance of money
and i think over time basically bitcoin
just
first of all through what we're doing
just talking about this
this decentralized media and educational
effort i think people are waking up to
the realities
of monetary inflation as they're feeling
the pain
right like something's not right here
even if people don't understand
cognitively what's going on
people in their procedural body
knowing they feel something's really
wrong
and so
i think
states are just going to keep pushing
and this creates a pressure on people to
learn more and find alternative means of
saving and preserving their wealth
being independent of the state
that creates capital inflows into
bitcoin
and so as bitcoin continues to grow
these lessons spread
and now when a country wants to go to
war
they're going to have to go tax and
borrow because people because capital if
you try to inflate the currency to pay
for that war capital will leave your
country
so it's i see bitcoin as a
disincentive to warfare in the long run
and the final piece of that is
bitcoin custodied properly is really
hard to steal so if you ever had a
central bank say on a bitcoin standard
when nazi germany invaded poland
they they when the
war the invasion of poland they go
straight to their central bank seize all
their gold right they just had a very
expensive war effort to do that they
need to go recoup their costs
well rerun that on a bitcoin standard
it's like you would invade poland
go straight to their central bank and
there'd be nothing there
presumably you'd the central bank would
have custody did it in multi-sig or
whatever
and there'd be no carrot right there's
no carrot to warfare at that point
so you're reducing the size of the
carrot to warfare
and you're reducing the ability of
states to fund warfare via inflation
so this is like a massive tectonic
incentive shift away from warfare in the
long run
so as you speak i have a million
questions that are just firing so just
bear with me here okay
so the first point was that i do agree
with peterson and that i think a lot of
war is very philosophical and emotional
um the last
uh war between israel and gaza i was
actually sitting in a bomb shelter in
israel when max kaiser tweeted bitcoin
fixes this
um
and so i do take the stance that i think
that
somehow you know
religious wars would continue regardless
of
a bitcoin standard however
when you say at the end of the day war
still costs money
and if the average american you know has
to lay down 80 000 dollars
i don't think they're going to be
supporting the war in afghanistan even
if it was philosophical religious
spiritual emotional
um
so that's interesting
yeah you just look at the cost to
benefit of violence right this could be
local violence even a guy breaking into
your house right it's a very risky
endeavor it's gonna break in your house
doesn't know
who's there are you armed
what's gonna happen
he's only gonna engage in that risky
enterprise if there's some carrot right
there's i'm going to steal the gold
there's still the diamonds
but in this
vision of a bitcoin eyes world where
things are stored in multi-sig it's
really hard to steal really expensive if
not impossible to steal that carrot goes
away
so it's like people just being rational
i'm not seeing
this in people i was like what do you
mean it'll never stop violence it'll
never stop coercion i'm not saying it
stops it i'm just saying you've
massively shifted the incentives away
from it right that guy that was thinking
about breaking into your house because
he had a
whatever percentage roi expectation that
expectation has been crushed and now
he's better off probably going to get a
job over here and just trading and
cooperating with people to produce an
roi for himself
so that's what i'm saying it's like we
we're not purely rational economic
actors i agree with that i know people
fight over all types of passionate
things like i get that
but
the
systemization of conflict at scale tends
to be a rational affair
you're going to do it if there's
something to be gained and bitcoin makes
it such that there is less to be gained
from conflict than there is from
cooperation
and you said that the
the war is paid for via inflation right
which therefore requires money to be
printed before the war um so this is
interesting
yeah
so what's interesting right now is we've
had um the pandemic trying to think of
ways to say that without red flags and
stuff like that um
yeah we've had one of them yeah pandemic
um and a lot of money was printed and
now
we are supposedly on on the verge of
world war three with inflation
skyrocketing i don't really think we are
but you know with inflation skyrocketing
and everything so
do you think there's it's almost is war
planned like do they print the money
ready to start inflation ready to ready
to pay for war is war planned
yes i am so
lost actually when i try to think
behind the eyes of statist and statism
i'm not sure if they are
very evil villain level coordinated you
know you hear all about um
these certain families that have run the
world for 500 years and it's all planned
it's been orchestrated yeah the
trilateral commission and the bilderberg
group all i don't know i don't know
frankly
i deviate between that and have you seen
the netflix movie don't look up oh my
god it was awful i thought i was gonna
throw up but i think government i
equally think government might yes also
just be like that
and it's
the thinking on the thinking there is
you become so frivolous and worthless
and incompetent when you can just press
money and like confiscate wealth it's
like you have no ins there's no
check there's no reconciliation to
reality that's sharpening you and
hardening you
and and conditioning you to you have no
skin in the game frankly you just don't
feel cost or pain so you just grow
um there's an atrophy an atrophy of of
the brain that occurs in that sphere and
clearly i'm speaking generally here i
know there's politicians that are maybe
fighting for life liberty property and
all that
it's not black or white but in general
i think when you can just confiscate
money at will
it's you have every incentive
let's say this way it's much easier to
spend other people's money than your own
correct that's my problem essentially
you just be frivolous right well social
democracy is the same
anywhere there's taxation or inflation
it's not their money it's being
confiscated yeah it's incredible it's
all theft so if you derive your revenues
via theft do you think it's entirely
theft
100. 100
so did you did you get to negotiate your
tax bill last year did you have the
power to say no
absolutely not i remember i paid it and
i was very upset about it can you opt
out can you exit the jurisdiction now
some you can some you could actually be
like i don't like the rate here i'm
going somewhere else
um
in the u.s i think two million dollars
you have a two million dollar net worth
which is a lot of money but it's not an
incredible amount of money you can't
even opt out you try to say i don't want
to be in the us anymore i'm gonna leave
you get hit with an exit tax
so you can't say no what's the exit tax
how much is that i don't know okay but
they tax part of your net worth when you
say
imagine going to a car dealership and
you're gonna buy a car and you can't
come to terms you're like i'm gonna
leave your car dealership now and they
say actually you're gonna pay me that's
literally like um it's literally a [ __ ]
coin there are so many projects out
there that say if you sell we'll tax you
to sell and then they make it sound like
a good thing because it's just like nah
it's so we can make people hold fiat's
the ultimate [ __ ] coin
literally by definition right one node
database the federal reserve it's an sql
database maintained on premise
governed by seven guys i guess
and they uh
there's no it's all proof of stake so
proof of stake add as many zeros as they
want
and you get no say-so
how many dollars are there who gets to
decide
what are their criteria for deciding
who's profiting who's who's collecting
the senior ridge on the us dollar none
of this is talked about no this is voted
upon there's no democratic process
it's the most twisted game in the world
it's the biggest pyramid scheme in human
history so
what would your ideal world look like
don't just say a bitcoin standard
because what does that mean right like
do you believe
there's okay there should be some level
of democracy should we have people
should we vote on every issue so we have
direct democracy
um
what is your ideal world look like
i think first of all the free market
itself is an actual economic democracy
the idea of democracy that we have today
representative democracy
again
based on the reality that property can
be violated right that's what's funding
the mechanism
and that's also what's being used to
impose the decisions that come out of it
if the 51 vote for a thing they now need
to impose on the 49 percent
that's based on the viability of
property if property weren't violated
weren't viable rather they would just
split when there's a disagreement so i
think the distant long run and this is
very much influenced by the book i talk
about a lot the sovereign individual
is that i think software you know
andreessen said software's eating the
world 10 or 15 years ago
proved to be exceptionally prescient
i think software is also eating the
state
so i think we move from a world over
time i don't know how long this is going
to take when i say this people think i'm
crazy they're like it'll never happen
we have 200 some odd countries today i
think we have 20 000
after some period of time i don't know
hundreds of years
thousands of years i'm not sure
but it
our socio-economic realities come to
reflect our technological realities so
the nation state was a large governance
structure for
industrial scale technologies we now are
most most of our attention is flowing
through digital technologies the
microprocessor right
the era of mass customization and
communication and all this i think our
sovereignty structures our socioeconomic
systems will come to reflect that so
much more decentralization
much more small scale governance much
more grassroots everything right much
more options many more options for
people
so that's the trajectory i don't know
how long it takes so
that was gonna be my next question um i
did an interview with mark moss and he
sort of talks about you know peak
centralization at 2025 and how
we're living through the one of the most
unprecedented eras whereby you know
we're seeing peak centralization from a
financial standpoint technological just
it's just everything um
and it feels like it's it's reaching its
peak
um i think covid was was really part of
that um inflation highest in 40 years
so do you think
the net because you know we have the
social credit system coming in cbdc's
which we can get into
um
but do you think we're actually going to
get to that sort of authoritarian level
do you think it's going to get much
worse or do you think
a bitcoin standard are not a syrian
bitcoin standard yet but do you think
bitcoin or this idea of freedom of
decentralization is going to come in
and solve the issue of authoritarianism
that we're seeing
i think it's going to play out unevenly
around the world you know one one thing
i really liked with my conversation from
bellagio is he has this thesis of
centralized east decentralized west
okay um makes a lot of sense actually
china's already
super centralized they've got this thing
rolled out they have the people
effectively conditioned where
almost like they've taken that stockholm
syndrome of statism to like across
multiple generations so people
it's sad really
one of the things i've
one of the ways i've come to look at the
world is that we are programmable
those of us that understand that we'll
strive to program ourselves right we'll
choose the things we eat the people we
spend our time with the books we read
our circumstances the businesses we run
our lifestyle
those that don't understand that though
can be preyed upon by those that do and
that seems to be that fiat slash
totalitarian impulse right
um
so that
i don't know you know i think there's
gonna be pockets of different things
happening around the world but again the
long run is
the more you oppress
people
the more you drive talent and capital
away from that oppression smart money
and smart people will go to where they
are treated best
and in the 21st century
via the internet via bitcoin
via telecommunications via encryption
uh
capital and interpersonal mobility is
higher than ever
so i just don't think this this control
mechanism is going to be as effective in
the 21st century
as it was historically
all that said there's also the dystopian
view which is what china is doing today
right so if you can get that rolled out
on top of people without them
understanding
if we can roll out cbdc's in this
country and
you know they always wrap it in some
moral camouflage or some
ubi like incentive you know sign up for
your wallet and get your free money and
here's your your bug provider so you
don't need steak anymore you just eat
the bugs
yeah let's go into that um so
you mentioned um that people are
programmable um and then you said
once you know that you can then choose
the foods you eat so this is fascinating
i want to go into the food topic
actually um because this is something
i've recently stumbled across um i'm
obviously british and in the uk the
food's all right there
a lot of the way the food is processed
in the us is actually illegal um in the
eu and you can tell when i've traveled
in europe it's much better oh well i can
tell i was here for three months at the
end of um 2021 and i like my body blew
up like i literally put on so much
weight
i was still hungry i wasn't overeating i
put on so much weight um and now i've
hired a nutritionist
and now i'm back in the us and i'm fine
um but i didn't realize what goes on
with the food here i had no idea
this is another interesting
aspect of the bitcoin rabbit hole
because you start
you know you start seeing through the
fiat illusion and again not just money
not just law it's also like i would
argue food and culture
um the food thing's interesting the
biggest one that i'm on now is seed oils
yep everyone's on seed oils they're in
everything with a label
even the healthy snack crackers or
almond butter bar or whatever healthy
food you think you're eating it probably
has seed oil in it
so and what's wrong with seed oils
i'm not well versed enough to
sit here and lay out a scientific
explanation of what's wrong but i can
relate my personal experience so
when i was in my 20s
i used to feel
very robust and healthy i think as most
of us do
as i got to 30 i started to have issues
and whatnot
um i'm now 36 today i cut out seed oils
probably eight to 12 months ago pretty
seriously i mean there were there were
i was already experimenting with
carnivore a couple of years prior to
that so i'd kind of like accidentally
cut out seed oils before i really knew
about them
um i guess the gist of what's wrong with
them is when you cook or consume these
oils that are not naturally occurring or
either compressing a lot of oil or
taking a lot of seed to make a little
bit of oil
it just our body doesn't deal with it
well it causes negative things there's a
lot of twitter accounts you can go
follow on research and all that to get
more information
for me personally
i went from
barely one of the main things i noticed
i could barely stand 15 minutes of
sunlight like direct sunlight like i
would start to get just
just feel burnt right i needed to get
out of the sun
i've been living in hawaii the past 14
months when i got real serious on this
really just eating
beef salt fruit raw milk
and we cook everything at home like
there's no seed oils don't eat out don't
mess around at all
i started being able to go into the sun
for just hours and hours and hours and i
wouldn't really get burned i'd go surf
like all day with sun cream on or no
something no no really yeah
and then
i've always had uh sort of dry skin like
on my arms and face so i've always had
to put moisturizer on stop needing to do
that
um
i've had different kinds of inflammation
like in my joints around my nose things
like this all that started to go away um
gut inflammation not feeling well like
all that went away
um
so it's been
been quite transformative for me and it
it really is that simple like i've tried
i tried a lot of interventions before i
got into this diet thing um but just
eating
the foods that we've been eating for
millions of years turns out to be
pretty good for you
yeah we've been uh eating meat as well
right
we're adapted to it so
the diet i mean i could so the diet i
was having was a frozen berry raw milk
smoothie in the morning
and then i was when you say raw milk
what do you mean
like cow's milk straight from the cow oh
straight from the cave yeah we had a
provider in kauai which you can't i
don't think it's legal to drink raw milk
so we had a provider in hawaii you know
we go and pick it up uh once a week it's
delicious but is the and how's the cow
fed and raised
uh they are just
organic
i i don't know if they eat grass or
grain but they're just free-range cows
in hawaii so
um
so make the smoothie and then lunch
dinner was basically just beef and salt
beef and salt
i would also mix in some
sauerkraut and other fermented foods
occasionally
all that did well for me but
it was it's good it improved a lot of
things that were going wrong in my 30s
so
i highly recommend
studying about seed oils studying about
the carnivore diet
um and it's not it's not just carnivore
because carnivore is like just beef and
salt right again having fruit and
whatnot added to this
uh they call it the abundance diet
there's a great actually a friend of
mine paul
he's at carnivoremd on instagram okay
he's a doctor he talks about all this uh
there's like a spectrum right where
meat and organs were the most desired
foods then fruit
and vegetables and grains legumes all of
this so there's a whole spectrum and if
you just focus on eating
the healthy end of the spectrum you tend
to do better and it's not one size fits
all we're all adapted to different
things we have different ancestral
pathways so you have to do some
experimentation and figure out what
works for you
but
it changes everything in life once you
get a hold of it yeah it's interesting
um
because there is this push in society
again in the media there's more
propaganda when it comes to your diet
and you mentioned
um eating bugs instead of meat and
there's that film i think it's called
snow sniper or something snow peas
okay um
let's delve into this so
why
is that propaganda right now
staring people away from meat and i
think i even saw maybe an article on
bloomberg or one of them which was um
saying you know bugs are actually better
for you than meat
i
the one that really scared me as i saw
a quote from klaus schwab if i'm saying
his name correctly do you know what who
cares if you're not saying you're crazy
they're real life dr evil yeah
real life james bond villain yeah
basically saying that
we need to abolish this is the head
of the world economic forum as i
understand it we need to abolish private
property
and stop eating meat like this is one
little quote of his i'm not saying it
exactly but paraphrasing
the fact that someone
that's the head of the world economic
forum can blatantly say we need to
abolish private property
when an economy is not possible you
cannot have an economy
without property
property is your relation to the fruit
of your labor that you then trade with
others to produce the economy
when you have the head of the world
economic forum saying we need no more
property
that's not what he's saying he's saying
property for me not for thee
right
question that question that property is
the basis of civilization if there's an
individual telling you we need to
abolish private property it's equivalent
to saying we need to abolish
civilization
read iron rand read read mises like this
is very cut and dry
and then so that's scary and disgusting
enough
but then they're saying okay and we also
need to stop eating meat
meat is the most desirous food
and we've literally been eating it for
millions of years
who is this guy that's been around for
80 something years to come on the scene
or his organization whatever and tell us
what we should eat i mean it's one of
the most
scary uh specters of freedom violation i
can imagine to try and dictate by fiat
what you eat it's it's insane so i just
really want to understand the fiat
place here it's because
it's the legislation
you eat whatever you want who can tell
you what to eat
i agree with you but it's the fear right
because you say dictate by fiat yes well
i guess maybe i'm double emphasizing it
in that case but to dictate what someone
eats
to
eat this eat what i tell you
or i will hurt you that's what fiat
means do this whatever it is eat this
thing because i said so
or i will hurt you they don't need to
say all that right there can just be a
veiled thread of force behind it
right just like there there are laws you
know do this
or else you break the law you suffer the
consequences
when that starts to be applied to your
dietary choice i mean you are what you
eat right
this is a very
concerning
attack on freedom and i think
i think you've just got to stand up for
it and do not comply frankly like over
my dead body will you ever tell me what
to eat i will eat whatever i want
how far would you go all the way
all the way
i'd like to get your just on that then
i'd like to get your opinion um on
djokovic
um so um the tennis player
he didn't go to australia to play the
big game
because he wasn't he hadn't had the the
medicine right
um and i was really impressed by that
actually
um because a lot of people especially
you know on twitter and you have all
these these big alpha accounts or
whatever and sort of talk about
freedom and all this stuff um but when
it came down to it he was willing to
sacrifice his career hmm good for him
right yeah
so how far would you go literally over
your dead body freedom maximalism
like i will stand for it to my death
and i hope
that
if that comes to pass
that i am at least a shining example for
others
i think it's important um
that's what we need more of a society i
think that's actually the problem a lot
of people
um
aren't
don't have the courage don't have the
bravery and don't have the strength um
i think
that's sort of why we see
i believe the emasculation of men from
the media um and things like that um so
in your opinion
honestly do you see
there being
do you see that there's an agenda being
pushed here
well certainly when you're talking about
the abolition of private property i mean
i don't know how you could call that
anything but an agenda because we have
private property
to some extent in the world
um
again thank god for bitcoin the ultimate
form of private property
if you want to abolish that then that is
i mean that is by definition an agenda
right it's changing a thing that exists
so
i don't know again back to the
government conversation like how
coordinated and intelligent is this
versus just
people that have just lost their mind
right if you look
if you spend too much time in the ivy
ivory tower you just lose touch with the
real world so maybe they think they're
just
the bill gates or whoever at that level
we don't need these things anymore i
have this new solution
but
this is very important too
in paradise loss
uh
milton has this line he says
evil is the knowledge which believes
itself complete
so when someone has a model of the world
a mental model of the world that they
think is the final answer
right
and they're trying to impose that onto
others that is evil right what is good
is what is what people discover what
people naturally move towards through a
free market discovery process right i
have wants
i have felt uneasiness as mises says i
go into the world i engage in voluntary
exchange with others to try and solve
that
usually solving a problem i have is also
a problem other people have so i can be
an entrepreneur and sell that solution
into the marketplace others are doing
the same we all cooperate we increase
wealth to increase human satisfaction we
create civilization
if instead i try to take that mental
model and impose it on people
i'm engaging in evil
so
these i and the the pernicious thing
about evil too is that i
i am i tend to believe that someone like
that may actually think they're doing
good right he may actually think he's
saving the world in his heart of hearts
i don't know but i could just speculate
to think that maybe claudia was like no
we have to do this to save the world
we're going to destroy the world if we
don't do this he may actually think he
is
a good man doing the right thing and
he's being righteous in his action
but
that's dangerous right that's deceptive
he's being misled by his own
idea of imposing a mental model on
others rather than letting people
discover what's best for them
so it's all to do with that relationship
between the people the government and
private property
and
though the way bitcoin comes into it is
because obviously it's decentralized
right you truly own that so if we look
at a bitcoin standard and a world where
you know bitcoin's been adopted
does that include
let's
say the deed to your house
being on the bitcoin network as an nft
or something like that i don't know
how you know there's a lot of
experiments being done where you can
execute property transactions and higher
protocols on the bitcoin network that
would be independent of state
authorization but
when it comes to again property being
the relationship between people and
their stuff so physical people in
relation with their physical stuff and
the physical world you're gonna need
physical security
to satisfy that
i don't think
i think it's gonna be a much smaller
business overall basically like it's a
business that's blown itself up on fiat
i say i mean expanded itself excessively
on fiat
but when property can be secured
more cheaply
and when there's less incentive to
violence like we talked about earlier
the need for physical security should be
reduced as well so the physical security
business model should shrink as well
do you truly think that we're going to
get onto a bitcoin standard
i don't know how you stop it
bitcoin is like this
vortex of positive incentives so i think
when you see the game theoretic aspects
of it
that
everyone's
cooperating competing in the marketplace
to try and secure economic value for
themselves
we all have an incentive to hold that in
a medium
that is most resistant to the opinions
of others
right i want to hold my money my
uh economic life force or monetary
energy as sailor might say i want to
hold that in something that no one
else's opinions or behaviors or actions
can affect
right the most untouchable asset is the
most desirous asset
and that's what bitcoin is can't inflate
it can't confiscate it can't interrupt
the network can't turn it off can't
reverse it can't stop it
so
how does that not become
how how is bitcoin i can't imagine
bitcoin not
having
um
an incredible amount of demand in a
world
where we're freezing the bank accounts
of peaceful protesters
where we're freezing the foreign
reserves of russia when they go to war
like this pain that people and
institutions are going to feel
through the security vulnerability of
fiat that it can be shut off canceled
c's etc that's going to push them into
and towards this untouchable asset
that's my opinion do you think that the
increasing
authoritarianism that we're seeing you
mentioned canada you mentioned um
freezing um
you know seizing accounts of russians
and so on do you think that in a
perverse way that's kind of going to be
good for bitcoin in terms of waking
people up
pain is information
literally that's how organisms adapt
right
they're dealing with some
situation in their environment that
they're not
if it's a giraffe trying to eat the tree
and it's not long enough it's feeling
the pain of not getting the food that it
wants and then over many generations its
neck gets longer
or the turtle gets attacked and there's
some maybe gap in its shell that one of
its
uh predators is exploiting and then over
time the turtle shell adapts like we
we are informed by pain and you know
this in your own life right if you've
ever
if you just win and succeed over and
over and over that can lead you astray
actually it's those times where you
screw up and you learn a lesson the hard
way that's what reforms you changes your
character that's what working out is
right you go into the gym and you
consciously apply physical adversity to
your body to force it to adapt
and working out hurts right you can't
have
in you can't
put yourself in formation without pain
so all the educational effort that we do
i think it's very important and i'd love
to be a part of it but sort of
paradoxically
government action is the greatest
billboard for bitcoin in the world and
i'll never we will never be able to
speak louder than that
and so
yes in my opinion it's a bit unfortunate
but it is fundamental to reality that
people and organisms learn through pain
i think you're i totally agree with you
um a lot of people talk about nfts and
all this stuff being the road to
adoption but i think it's just fun you
know um i think it's the pain
where the innovation comes from um so
what would you say right now where are
we at right now because there's
obviously a lot of um hostility from
governments particularly in the u.s um i
think it was elizabeth warren that just
refused to be taught
about bitcoin and you know its
connection to illicit activity or being
able to enable illicit activity so
where are we at with bitcoin adoption
right now
i had a guest on um past few days
mr larry lepard and he said
we are at 25
of u.s population holding bitcoin i
didn't know it was that high
i thought we were a sub 10
um
i don't know i don't know and i don't
know that you can even trust the data
necessarily i'm not sure how it's
derived i don't i don't spend a lot of
time trying to figure it out either so
maybe there's a way to figure it out
accurately i'm not sure
um i'm just looking at the
incentives ultimately like what's
happening in the world and what are
people's incentives in the long run and
so
it's really hard to predict the future
but i think if you look
at economics you can at least establish
a probabilistic trajectory for things
right like
you could have if you understood the
internet you probably could have figured
out that traditional media was
[ __ ] 20 years ago right you just
understand
the economic model is superior right
it's cheaper distribution zero cost of
bandwidth
you know improves margins for creators
things like this so if you just
look at the economic circumstances
within a given technological paradigm i
think it gives you some indication of
the direction the world's going
and so very simply with bitcoin
in a world where everyone's printing
money
everyone like every central bank is
violating the private property rights of
their citizenry
at an unprecedented rate
the money that no one can print right
the property that no one can violate
becomes increasingly desired in that
world
and you can't reverse the fiat this fiat
debt spiral like you keep
you need to print more and more money to
keep the system sustainable so
inflation is not linear right it's
it's exponential
went from a 700 billion dollar bill out
in 2008 to 20 trillion and 20 20.
the next one's probably going to be in
the hundreds of trillions and before you
know it
bread and milk are going to be thousands
of dollars and the dollars are not going
to make sense anymore they're not going
to be relevant they're not going to hold
their value
you won't even be able to think in it
you know in weimar germany
things got so bad
that people would order all their beers
at the beginning of the night
because they would increase the price of
beer three or four times throughout the
night one night at the bar
so you'd go to the bar and you'd order
your 10 beers or whatever the beginning
of the night and that was where was this
and when this is weimar germany in the
20s i believe wow
hyperinflation's really really really
bad just spend the next 24 hours
count how many times you use money or
think in money or negotiating money now
imagine that money has lost all meaning
and you can't how do you do anything how
do you do anything
how long do you think the us dollar has
left
i have a public prediction that the us
dollar is hyperinflated into
worthlessness by 2035.
i could be wrong i just looked at
historical hyperinflations the timing of
them
in terms of percentage
of supply increase where again it gets
orders of magnitude worse each time
there tends to be a breaking point
hyperinflation i think is 50
month over month inflation price
inflation is the technical definition
for for hyperinflation
and i think we get there by 2035 just
based on some proxies from history you
made a tweet recently um which was
pretty controversial
um
after this conversation is sort of
starting to make a little bit more sense
um
sex is was it rapist as sex as fiat is
to bitcoin something like that yeah
let's go into that what did you mean
what did you mean by that tweet yeah i
was accused of trivializing rape um
i was also accused of making a category
error
and that i should never compare these
two things but
the the end of the tweet was
mutual consent matters right
and it does right the difference between
sex and rape is consent
the difference between a transaction and
theft
is consent
the difference between a job
and slavery is consent
the power to say no is the root of
sovereignty if you can't if you don't
have the power to say no if someone's
physically coercing you
over your
attestation to the contrary like stop no
i want to leave no more of this
then that's a non-consensual exchange
and you're in the realm of immorality
and evil in my estimation
um
it could have been
an insensitive tweet because i know
people have been through things that are
horrible and terrible but
hyperinflations are pretty horrible and
terrible and the wars that fiat currency
funds are pretty horrible and terrible
there were 169 million people murdered
in the 20th century
by states fiat funded states
i'll say that again
and this is from a state university
study university of hawaii study they
call it demicide it's such a huge
tragedy they gave it its own name
169 million people murdered in the 20th
century by fiat funded states
i know rape is bad
that's pretty bad too
yeah i understand um
i enjoyed the comments and i enjoyed the
the whole thing um but but i understand
it's the mutual
the lack of mutual consent um and
naturally if you talk about fiat and um
how it funds wars and war equals death
then you have rape and you have death so
they're both good sounds pretty bad and
um
and i was attacked and people like be
careful you're gonna get canceled again
and i'm like cancel me
what does this fiat cancel [ __ ]
cancel me i don't care
i'm sorry the tweet was not sensitive
unfollow me
okay i am actually genuinely sorry to
anyone that like took offense to it and
feel bad about it like i'm sorry but
i hope if you've listened to this
interview that i'm not trivializing
anything i'm very serious i think this
is the
number one problem we face as a species
is this element of coercion compulsion
violence
and it's all remedied by
putting all of our emphasis on mutual
consent in all human relations
and so you think that a bitcoin standard
is inevitable is that correct
i don't believe in the word word
inevitable you know there's no way to
know the future and
anyone that
lives by the crystal ball is bound to
eat glass but i just think
i call it an unstoppable vortex of
positive incentives it's probably one of
the best
phrases i've found for it you know it's
incentivizing everyone to contribute
to the proliferation and success of its
network that's how it works basically
it's ingenious
so if we don't destroy ourselves by fiat
first then i think bitcoin has a very
high likelihood of success
robert i want to thank you so much i
really appreciate you breaking down all
of those ideas um i've never actually
heard somebody speak about war and how
bitcoin truly fixes this um i know it's
this catchphrase that we hear in um in
the community a lot so i really
appreciate you taking the time to truly
explain how bitcoin fixes all of these
problems
thank you so much i really enjoyed the
conversation you asked great questions
thank you so much any final words you'd
like to offer
of wisdom i don't know when this is
airing but we're doing a live event on
friday night in miami that's april 8th
um it's going to be my air after
maybe maybe friday i'm not sure well um
we're also going to release a recording
of that live event the live events on
april 8th we have a special guest for
the what is money show we're going to
record in front of a live studio
audience in miami at the bitcoin 2022
conference
i will release that episode on youtube
and podcast probably two weeks later so
it's like end of april
um and i hope
and intend for it to be one of those
timeless bitcoin discussions so
i hope you guys will check it out
guys don't forget to follow robert on
all socials he has a newsletter he has a
youtube twitter and am i missing
anything else no that's it yeah the
freedom analytics is the sub stack the
what is money shows the youtube and
podcast and twitter is at breedlove2020
22 breedlove22 not 2022. that's really
tongue twisted me a lot this year so far
yeah i can imagine robert thank you so
much thank you so much guys thanks so
much for watching please don't forget to
hit the subscribe button so you never
miss another fantastic interview we'll
see you next week